nicht der fahrerseite des autos
[Musik]
der film heißt bahn db und ist einer aus
dieser nicht enden wollenden dürfen dann
aber vielleicht irgendwann mal sollen
transformers reihe
das sind sehr langweilige roboter filme
in denen man halt am boden kauert
während der geschirrspüler parat und der
wäschetrockner sich gegenseitig
vernichten wollen
um diesen krieg zu beenden
aber bumblebee ist total gut richtig
super league einen super spitzenfilm sie
kann die helfen deine gefühle
auszudrücken besuchstag hailee steinfeld
als junge mechanikerin oder ingenieure
oder ingenieure oder wie wollt findet
einen alten vw käfer in gelben der
natürlich ein außerirdischer roboter ist
was sonst den sie dann retten muss oder
er muss sie retten oder irgendwie müssen
sie einander retten was sie aber vor
allem retten ist diese blöde
transformers film reihe die man jetzt
fast aushält geschaffen das durch
allerlei abenteuer aber auch dadurch
dass diese ganzen science fiction
fantasy franchise es jetzt plötzlich
mädchen rein geteilt werden da gibt es
ja so jede menge jungs die sagen wieso
hat star wars jetzt ein mädchen wieso
als star trek discovery jetzt eine frau
wir wollen unseren alten kaiser wilhelm
wiederhaben blablabla und hier kann man
aber sehen bei bumblebee warum das total
gut es ist erlaubt nämlich einfach
andere geschichten ist erlaubt einfach
geschichten bei denen du nicht weißt wie
es ausgeht und wie es weitergeht weil
das nicht schon tausend mal gesehen hast
zum beispiel die liebesgeschichte mit
dem männlichen hauptdarsteller dessen
namen nicht dauernd vergessen der aber
total charmant ist und in einer
geschichte mit dem jungen als helden
wäre es natürlich so gewesen dass dieser
welt angehimmelt wird weil er ein held
ist während hier der junge ein riesiges
problem damit hat dass die frau ebene
heldin ist so dass er nicht so richtig
weiß was jetzt eigentlich seine rolle
ist und dann tappen sie da so rum und
haben diese wunderbaren
koordinationsprobleme während die ganze
zeit alles einstürzt und in flammen
aufgeht
ich lasse dich nicht im stich
also leute die transformers filme mögen
müssen da unbedingt rein weil denen ist
ja offensichtlich alles egal das heißt
sie müssen einfach in jedem film zur
strafe wenn sie schon in transformers
filme gehen leute die aber transformers
-film schrecklich finden können von der
phantastischen drehbuchautoren christina
horsten die dasding geschrieben hat
lernen dass selbst transformers filme
gut gehen damit das alte gesetz erfüllen
und alles was ein mensch und nicht etwa
eine maschine alles was ein mensch
machen kann kann man auch schön und gut
da hatte ich bin sowas von erledigt der
männliche hauptdarsteller heißt george
lindenberg junior oder corel ende juni
oder lindenberg